Donald Trump absolutely dissembled
during the weekend Whitehouse
coronavirus press briefings and I
challenge you today to tell me what on
earth Donald Trump is talking about here
he actually seems ill in this video he's
not making any sense I cannot for the
life of me figure out what Donald Trump
is talking about but let's play it it's
the stuff of Horrors back to the scene
that you used to have which was look I
could tell you about and I'm not gonna
do it because I didn't want to bring it
up but I could tell you about events
that took place and I said things like
you'll never do that again or you'll
never do this again
or I don't want to make sure the events
I don't want to mention what you're
supposed to be doing because and you
know one of them was so horrible I said
a certain industry will be out of
business never happen again two weeks
later was like nothing ever happened
hopefully we get rid of this we have
tremendous talent up here and all over
including governor's that doesn't make
sense there is nothing there there is no
substance what Trump is talking about is
impossible to ascertain from what he is
saying look at a transcript of this it
doesn't mean anything
back to the scene which you used to have
which was look I could tell you about
and I'm not gonna do it because I didn't
want to bring it up but I could tell you
about events that took place and I said
things like you'll never do that again
or you'll never do this again or I don't
even want to mention the events I don't
want to mention what you're supposed to
be doing because and you know one of
them was so horrible I said a certain
industry will be out of business never
happen again
two weeks later was like nothing ever
happened hopefully we get rid of this we
have tremendous talent up here and all
over including governor's I don't know
what he's talking about this is not the
way someone who is of sound mind
communicates with people never mind on a
daily basis for hours day in and day out
where the reporters just have to sit
there and wait for it to end and ask
their next question here's another one
from
following day which again makes
absolutely no sense it's an unhinged and
wacky rant attacking the media as
thousands of Americans per day continue
to die sources say you know what sources
say man
sources say means they have nobody and
they make it up okay and they have a few
other type statements that mean the same
thing but sources say is the most often
used expert in the Washington Post New
York Times especially CNN fake news CNN
they should really be mandated and I
mean mandated to use a name if there's a
source username so there is Trump
demanding that journalistic convention
around sources sources of course an
absolutely critical element of
journalism be thrown out and all sources
must be named you can't have that you
can't say sources here you can't have an
anonymous source of course remember
anonymous sources typically are
anonymous to the public but the reporter
knows who they are and Trump just
continuing to do this thing where he
attacks the basic conventions of
journalism and press freedom and then
Trump going on to talk about testing and
just how amazing and great everything is
and sort of promoting coronavirus tests
as if they're some new iPhone or
something like that that are just going
to crush the competition take a look I
don't believe the sources exist and I
try and tell this you know the beautiful
thing about doing these conferences is
that we have tremendous numbers of
viewers and I'm able to reach the
viewers without having to go through
fake news where they make a good story
into a bad story so with all of that
it's been an incredible period of time
we've done a fantastic job with the talk
of other nations the leaders of other
nations are calling us for help they're
calling us for equipment they're calling
us for testing capacities now with the
testing we are going further Deborah is
going to talk about that now with the
testing we have some other tests coming
up that are going
to be I think phenomenal I think they're
going to blow away everything as soon as
they come out and we're gonna get them
out as soon as possible but I'd like to
ask dr. Burks to come up and say a few
words about where we've come how far
we've come and more importantly where
we're going from this point because
honestly it's it's quite amazing thank
you very much that's the President of
the United States if you can believe it
and then the testing thing we're going
to do a deeper dive into testing
tomorrow remember that the testing thing
is is now a way to scapegoat governor's
for Donald Trump Trump has been bragging
for months about how all that's
happening with testing is because of him
and that we're testing the best and
we're testing the most and all of the
stuff now that Trump's talking about
reopening and numerous public health
officials are making clear we just don't
have the tests to reopen right now Trump
is very quickly shifting and talking
about hey listen these governors have to
test you know I mean we're doing what we
can here but the governor's really need
to do the testing the numbers right now
are we're testing about a hundred and
fifty thousand a day yesterday we tested
I think about a hundred and sixty seven
thousand that's the most we've tested in
the day that needs to more than triple
to get us to a minimum for reopening we
need at least 500,000 tests a day that
we're doing not that are sitting
somewhere 500 thousand a day minimum one
roadmap says we need a million tests a
day to reopen one roadmap says we really
need 22 million a day to reopen which is
a crazy number but that would let you
test the whole country on a rolling
basis every two weeks
in any case Trump now starting to shift
blame on testing to governor's and then
lastly here's Trump trying to humiliate
a reporter whose question he doesn't
like by interrupting and insisting the
guy tell him who he works for
and flippantly telling the guy yeah keep
reading your question of everything get
the American people don't understand why
you're unwilling to use the awesome
powers of your presidency to make
American companies manufacture the PPE
and also the testing equipment that you
implement the implement your
recommendation enough but who are you in
a culture I'm with tmn recommendations
for me and what does tell immediate news
what my name is Doug Christian with talk
media news go ahead keep reading your
question so increasingly you're seeing
networks just not carrying the full
press briefings and it's tough because
new policy is announced that these press
briefings pretty often so here's my view
on it the mike pence part is worthless
pence goes up there he never announces
any new guidelines he praises Trump for
his leadership he lists the number of
you know masks that air bridge flights
are ordering or whatever I mean it's
it's absolutely meaningless so my policy
now it increasingly has been and now it
will be on a hard-and-fast basis I will
be muting the Mike Pence part it's
worthless the Trump part I do the best I
can to fact-check so that when Trump
lies about testing or this or that fact
I try to instantly rebut it so that at
least my audience understands how the
disinformation is being formulated and
then we have the portion where we hear
from doctors which is actually useful to
the extent that the doctors are telling
us the full truth sadly dr. Burks is
increasingly a vector of mild
disinformation as well very clearly a
placating Trump in ways that go above
and beyond the sort of mere collegiality
of doctor foul Chi dr. Burks is actually
becoming a perpetuator of some of trumps
disinformation and then you have the
question session which I do actually
find interesting to see what reporters
ask but that's where we are right now in
terms of the press briefings and as you
can see very bizarre things are taking
place at these press briefings so now
that we've discussed how Donald Trump
allegedly pushed out a top vaccine
scientists because he was refusing to
promote the unproven coronavirus
treatment chloroquine that Donald Trump
liked I have video for you of Donald
Trump again being extremely triggered by
CBS reporter Wei Jia Jiang
during yesterday's White House
coronavirus press briefing when she
asked about dr. bright she referred to
dr. bright as having great gifts when it
comes to the work he was doing Trump
didn't like it why would a woman praise
dr. bright and not praise Donald Trump
all must praise Trump and Trump again
lashed out at her check it out for gifts
what do you know him you studied him
have you reported on him you said his
gifts his gifts great gifts this
actually seems pathological with Trump
and women who do not back down from him
Trump seems like a guy I've said before
Trump doesn't seem to have meaningful
relationships with women he doesn't seem
to have a meaningful relationship with
Melania what we know of his past
marriages don't suggest meaningful
relationships what we know about his
past mistresses and six-figure payoffs
don't suggest does not suggest
meaningful relationships with women
there seems to be an insecurity with
Trump where he is immediately threatened
and triggered by women who were actually
assertive and confident like wadiya's
yang and who have the potential to make
Donald Trump look really bad which she
often does quite effortlessly I must say
so what's going on here is very clear
she didn't praise Trump she's not
sucking up to Trump the way he thinks
women are supposed to do and she has the
audacity to praise another man it's very
difficult for Trump to handle as the
alpha male that he claims to be and
remember that this is the same reporter
that was told by Donald Trump a few days
ago hey take it easy take it easy
relax lower your voice who do you work
for and she is so getting under his skin
here's Trump pointing to her and saying
she wasn't called on during yesterday's
press briefing there's this constant
level of triggered Ness
that we see in Donald Trump as a result
of her presence there
we talked about this yesterday
babysitter Trump laying down the law on
CBS's Wei Jia Jiang but not on anybody
else for a while
it was cNN's Jim Acosta that was
regularly firing Trump up but Trump now
seems to have become kind of comfortable
with the adversarial relationship he
knows Jim Acosta will ask an adversarial
question he kind of seems to relish and
be comfortable with mixing it up with
Jim Acosta it is very different with
CBS's Wei Jia Jiang Trump does not seem
to relish the tough questions from her
he seems visibly uncomfortable he is
very easily triggered by her every
question and statement and every time
she speaks up seemingly very bothersome
to Donald Trump and I have to tell you I
absolutely love it so I'm still getting
through my stories about the
irresponsible virus disinformation
that's happening each weekend and a lot
of it is happening on Fox News and
there's so much of it it's taking me
through Tuesday to actually get caught
up on it so I want to go through a
little bit of judge Jeanine Pirro show
from this weekend on Fox News
here's judge Jeanine asking I know
people are dying I know people are sick
but what about the rest of us we just
have to stay home another example of
embracing the let them die strategy that
we talked about earlier today sheltered
in their homes who've been patiently
watching this unfold have seen the data
and the facts changed from day to day
first there were 2.2 million who were
supposed to die in the United States and
then it was a million then it was
500,000 then 250,000 and supposedly
mitigation was already taken into
account those numbers okay we have to
stop first of all a judge using the word
suppose ugly come on okay and she's
wrong 2.2 million was the possible death
toll if we did nothing and this is a
game that they're playing now to say hey
we could have lost 2.2 million and now
we might only lose 60,000 so therefore
Trump is a hero 2.2 million was if
literally nothing was done which no
president could actually get away with
it seemed like Trump was going to do
nothing at first but obviously he could
not actually get away with doing nothing
it's a ridiculous bar to be saying we
could have lost 2.2 million anything
shorter anything short of that is a
victory by Donald Trump let's continue
though and we understand there are so
many sick and dying and density and hot
spots are to be treated differently but
what about the rest of us we want to go
back to work
feed our families and as the governors
sit there and pontificate we are the
ones experiencing the reality that for
every percentage drop in employment
there are five to ten thousand deaths
occurring depression suicide domestic
violence child abuse resurgence of
alcoholism drug addiction loss of hope
battered women locked at home with their
abusers abused children not being
identified or protected because they
cannot go to school I'll wear my mask my
gloves and I'll keep my distance and
I'll do the testing whether to determine
if I have kovin or whether I have the
antibody but don't you even think about
tracing or tracking or giving me a card
it ain't happening if you're wondering
if she's drunk again I don't know the
answer judge Jeanine appeared visibly
impaired on her show a few weeks ago
it's less clear this time but she's
certainly not making any more sense
regardless people are sick and dying but
what about us the answer is you get to
live hopefully you hopefully don't get
sick or die that's what we are going for
here and judge Jeanine continues with
her rant and she does seem more unhinged
than normal whether it's an
alcohol-related or not I do I don't know
but very very unhinged your models are
out of control the economy is out of
control
China is the one that's out of control
we're not going to let you destroy this
country or our way of life we've worked
too hard and we fought too long to lose
it to a woman that's what I said a woman
virus that China knew about openly lied
about said it couldn't be transmitted
from human
human and intentionally protected
Chinese citizens from the virus but
allowed that virus to be released
putting the rest of the world at risk
you want to control people you
politicians want to flex your muscles
we'll start working on how you're going
to punish ostracize alienate and
financially sanction and make China
accountable for what they did to us and
the rest of the world of course the
economy recovers dead people don't
recover judge Jeanine who was actually a
judge once which is crazy he's ranting
in a way that's not that different from
the guy urinating in the subway station
while ranting about the second coming of
Christ or whatever there's then we get
to the cherry on top judge Jeanine
actually brings on a protester this is a
protester from Michigan and praises the
protester I guess for putting people at
risk of infection take a look Denny dent
Dingell who is the senator didn't have
nice things to say about you guys and I
was rather shocked here she is a
representative of your state criticizing
this this peaceful protest and it was
pretty peaceful saying it was
inexcusable what what are Michigan's
reaction to her well I can tell you look
at Michigan look span nation what we've
done with operation gridlock and has
ignited a fire that has spread across
this entire nation Arizona Pennsylvania
Texas I mean today New York great
example of gridlock people rising up all
across this nation all right and you
know a lot of people are very proud of
you Michonne and what you've done and
let me just say Debbie Dingell is a
congresswoman and not a senator of
course the issue isn't whether it was a
peaceful protest again they are just
completely changing the parameters of
the discussion the peaceful nature of
the Pro
isn't an issue the public health risk of
the protest is what's at issue they
called it operation gridlock they are
grid locking streets and preventing
patients who need care from getting to
hospitals and this is how the echo
chamber works we're seeing it happen in
real time
Trump tweets about liber8 Michigan
liber8 Minnesota whatever Trump says
protesters are being responsible even
when they're not and then judge Jeanine
brings on a protester and acts like
they're doing some amazing principled
thing when all they're doing is putting
people at risk of getting the virus and
compromising the long term economic
stability of the country remember
they're insisting that in the short term
opening will be good economically maybe
it will maybe it won't but what we know
from the 1918 flu pandemic is premature
opening is bad economically in the
medium term and here you see Fox News
sort of pick it up and carry water
openly promoting and supporting the
protests against social distancing
measures on which we are all relying to
keep us safe this is the situation in
which we find ourselves it's not a bad
dream we can't just wake up from it
we're dealing with this in reality
another element of unfortunate reality
is that this morning Donald Trump
devolved into a childish tweet storm
appearing to potentially even have a
psychotic break of some kind maybe under
pressure from the coronavirus Fiasco and
once again proving that we are at public
health risk by having this man as
president and at least nominally in
charge of the coronavirus response you
know if it's really Jared Kushner behind
the scenes or whoever it's bad no matter
what Trump is at least nominally in
charge look at what the president has
spent the morning tweeting first
attacking news coverage on MSNBC saying
watched the first five minutes of poorly
rated warning psycho on MSDN see just to
see if he is as nuts as people are
saying he's worse such hatred and
contempt I used to do his show all the
time before the 2016 election then cut
him off wasn't worth the effort his mind
is shot
remember that yesterday nearly 2,000
Americans died yesterday the death toll
was right around 1950 Trump insists
everything is fine and tweets quote it's
amazing that I became president of the
United States with such a totally
corrupt and dishonest lamestream media
going after me all day and all night
either I'm really good far better than
the fake news wants to admit or they
don't have nearly the power as once
thought then as the official number of
cases in the United States will pass
800,000 today Trump tweets about his
ratings saying quote I've had great
ratings my whole life there's nothing
unusual about that for me the White
House news conference ratings are
through the roof Monday Night Football
bachelor finale New York Times but I
don't care about that I care about going
around the fake news to the people
remember that the daily press briefings
are some of the most lie riddled
public-facing events that Donald Trump
has done in his presidency and then
lastly once again Trump tweeting about
these phantom approval ratings among
Republicans we never know where they're
coming from I think they might come from
just surveys that Donald Trump promotes
through YouTube channels saying quote
ninety-six percent approval rating in
the Republican Party thank you this must
also mean that most importantly we are
doing a good great job in the handling
of the pandemic now the truth is the
opposite in the last Gallup presidential
approval poll I told you about this
yesterday a Trump's approval dropped
nine points since the last poll that's
the fastest approval decline between
polls of Donald Trump's entire
presidency but none of it matters it's
all a question of what can his followers
be convinced of nearly 2,000 people died
yesterday were passing 800,000 cases
today testing has not actually increased
for weeks and Trump spends the morning
bragging about ratings and attacking
Mika Brzezinski and Joe Scarborough
MSNBC hosts this is not a president
maybe someday we will have one as if we
needed
real doctor to tell us that the protests
against coronavirus social distancing
were a bad idea
we now are hearing from top infectious
disease doctor Anthony foutch II who is
saying in clear terms these protests
will backfire these protests will slow
down the economic recovery now the
answer the response is of course
obviously but I'm sure that hearing it
from a doctor will make the protesters
take heed and understand the importance
right wrong protesters over the weekend
were actually caught on video chanting
fire foul Qi I played that video for you
yesterday let's look at yesterday's Good
Morning America on ABC here is doctor
foul Qi saying it himself
and finally sir we're seeing these
protests crop up all across the country
right now including the protests in
Texas and other places where they're
saying fire Anthony Fauci Falchi is
wrong they're resisting these stay at
home orders from governors what's your
message back to those protesters yeah
yeah me not I think you know that the
message is that clearly this is
something that is hurting from the
standpoint of economics and the
standpoint of things that have nothing
to do with the virus but unless we get
the virus under control the real
recovery economically is not going to
happen so what you do if you jump the
gun and go into a situation where you
have a big speed spike you're gonna set
yourself back so as painful as it is to
go by the careful guidelines of
gradually phasing in to a reopening it's
gonna backfire that's the problem unless
we get the virus under control none of
this matters by reopening now you will
get some short-term economic benefit
there will be nominally businesses that
go back online and start earning some
revenue and start paying some taxes okay
but over the long term the economics are
going to be worse from reopening the way
that these protesters want us to reopen
right now it's genuinely and truly sad
that this is simply another political
disagreement it's just another political
football to throw back
fourth the science is clear the medical
world is clear any premature opening is
going to lead to a spike in cases and in
the long run it will cost us dearly
maybe we get three to four weeks of
so-called economic productivity but it's
like the experiments about I don't
remember who did these but there's these
experiments with five-year-olds where
you go in and you put a cookie in front
of them and you say I'm gonna leave the
room if you wait ten minutes you'll get
a second cookie and some of the little
kids are more patient and they wait and
they get that second cookie and a lot of
people can't and they just need the
cookie anyway tons of people are stuck
on the idea of opening now without
realizing that if we do this difficult
thing we can hopefully open permanently
a little further down the road instead
of opening now and then having to close
again and then opening and closing
endlessly until we have a treatment and
a vaccine so of course dr. Anthony foul
he is correct but understand that once
again it's foul Chi and science on one
side and Trump and these sycophants on
the other side and we're supposed to
believe everything is just fine and
there's no obvious conflict there except
that Trump recognizes things are so bad
that he has to suspend immigration
altogether to the United States foul Qi
says do not open and do not protest
while Donald Trump said over the weekend
liberate Minnesota liberate Michigan
liberate Virginia and save your great
Second Amendment it is under siege and
remember that Trump also said over the
weekend the protesters are the ones
being treated roughly and that they are
protesting in a responsible manner well
I think we do have a so green guidance
but I think some things are too tough
and if you look at some of the states
you just mentioned it it's too tough not
only relative to this but what they've
done in Virginia with respect to the
second amendment is just a horrible
thing they did a horrible thing the
governor and he's the governor under a
cloud to start off with so when you see
what he said about the Second Amendment
when you see what other states have done
no I think I feel very comfortable go
ahead
just to be clear when you talk about
these states Michigan Minnesota Virginia
do you think that they should lift their
stay at home orders or can you talk
Knoblauch I think elements of what
they've done is too much it's just too
much you know the elements because I've
already said sir are you concerned
though that people coming out in protest
are going to spread coded to other
people they're congregating in ways that
health experts have said they should not
know these are people expressing their
views I see where they are I see the way
they're working they seem to be very
responsible people to me but it's you
know they've been treated a little bit
rough this is a direct contradiction I
know who I trust on it but there are
trumpets who want doctor foul she fired
for trying to keep America safe you need
only look at history to know what the
right path is look at studies of the
economic impact of the 1918 flu in the
United States we have found that the
cities that implemented the early
measures and kept them suffered no
adverse economic effects over the medium
term the short term was bad no doubt but
the states that opened earlier the
places that opened earlier in the 1918
flu pandemic did better in the short
term but much worse in the medium to
long term you've got a grin and bear it
in the short term you will do better in
the long term we can't miss the forest
for the trees here and sadly the
President of the United States is
actually encouraging these protesters to
do that dr. fowey is clear the science
is clear I don't know that we're going
to actually end up on the right side of
this one will have continued coverage of
this and other stories from today on the
David Pakman show
Instagram page if you were on Instagram
and I am go to david pakman show that is
our Instagram account while you're there
follow me at David Pakman my urban
garden soil has arrived I am planting I
will be documenting all of it on my
Instagram at David Pakman so to wrap up
our discussion of hydroxychloroquine and
how after an
number of studies showing it's not
helping patients and in fact may be
hurting Trump is no longer talking about
it Fox News is barely talking about it
both dr. Phil who is a psychologist not
a medical doctor and dr. oz who is a
medical doctor but is widely known for
promoting quack cures both of them have
been saying anti science things about
the virus but dr. oz has been
particularly a present as a promulgator
of chloroquine miracle treatment type
nonsense for many weeks now we now have
a study I told you about from the VA
which says this isn't working well it
might be hurting patients now credit to
Fox and Friends they actually did a
story this morning about that study and
they brought on dr. oz let's take a look
all right so let's move on to
hydroxychloroquine they did a study a
limited study at a VA hospital and they
came to the conclusion it did no benefit
and they still had 19 deaths what's your
reaction to that since who you've been
doing we've all been doing heavy work to
find out where if this works or not so I
hate to already be jumping in so quickly
but Brian Kilmeade is already rewriting
history Brian Kilmeade says we've been
doing heavy work to find out if this
works or if it doesn't work now dude
you've been promoting the drug just like
Trump has now that it's not working
he's rewriting history to say we've been
investigating with an open mind maybe it
works maybe it doesn't no that's not
what you were doing you're rewriting
history
let's now go to dr. oz well the VA study
looked at older and quite a bit sicker
patients all male patients in their
hospitals and they show that the drug by
itself didn't help it might harm that
population is you know they've been
other studies done this devious they was
retrospective they look back to see what
had happened because they weren't
gathering the data at the time that they
were actually giving them medications
studies that have done this
prospectively so looking forward and
giving it as they were as collecting
data as they're going along like in
France or the randomized trials from
China have shown benefits but only
really when that's given earlier to
patients so dr. oz mentions all the
reasons we might not be able to trust
this new study it was only male patients
well that's actually good in in most
good studies you
look at only men are only women to
eliminate sex as a possible a factor
that effects the results of the
treatment
it was retrospective well many of the
studies that are being done are but the
most disturbing thing is that dr. oz
mentions that French study the French
study dr. oz mentions as a counterpoint
had under 40 participants and no control
group the VA study at least had close to
a sample size of 400 and again dr. oz
could just tell the truth and stay and
say every study so far has had some
issues but this is a bigger study and it
doesn't look good instead dr. Oz says
well you know you've got this study and
you've also got the French study with
the 36 or the 38 patients with no
control group and he says that one
looked good even if this one doesn't
very dishonest he also mentions studies
from China that looked good I won't even
comment on that now because later in the
segment oz himself says we really need
data from the United States if we need
US data why even bring up the Chinese
study now in this next segment he
actually does say the right thing which
is what I've been saying all along the
fact that matter is we don't know
thankfully these dr. Dee's medications
or prescription only so doctors are
desperately awaiting the completion of
the higher quality randomised trials and
we've covered them on the show several
times in South Dakota the University of
Minnesota has over a thousand patients
randomized there's additional trials
going on let's get that data so we know
what we're dealing with so that would
have been the right thing to say all
along which is we just have to wait
dr. foul she said we need randomized
controlled trials until we have those we
really don't know that's what they
should have been saying from day one a
little bit more here where Brian
Kilmeade introduces the z-pak element
which may actually make the treatment
even more dangerous and dr. oz just
white flags and says we've really just
gotta wait for the RCTs and just to
follow up real quick just is it
important to know what they're combining
it with and the dosage because it's not
supposed to be taking on his own don't
you have the z-pak there's a lot of
variables Brian I gotta say I think at
this point there's so much data coming
from so many places we
better off waiting for the randomized
trials doctor foul she's been asking for
otherwise is if we keep reacting will
begin back-and-forth for studies that
show opposite results and a lot of it
might have to do with when you get the
medication if you give it to people who
are already having breathing tubes down
their throat it might it's not gonna
have a same kind of effect as if you
give it early but we don't have the
randomized data from the United States
to educate us well enough right now
so again if dr. oz had said this on
April 1st I would be praising dr. oz I
would be saying hey you know what when
Trump was promoting it and you had just
this French study to tout even though it
had 38 people in it if then dr. oz said
now she's right we've just gotta wait
I would I would have respected him from
day one instead dr. oz and Fox and Trump
have all been promoting this and this
would have been the thing to say then
rather than to spend three weeks
promoting it only to now say you know
you really need randomized controlled
trials it's pathetic and with every
passing day hydroxychloroquine is a word
that is harder and harder to find both
coming out of Donald Trump's mouth and
coming out of Fox News broadcasting
really pathetic we've been saying it
from day one and they actually have been
spreading dangerous disinformation all
along we'll have more about this change
in tact when it comes to chloroquine on
the David Pakman show
Instagram page make sure you follow us
on instagram at david pakman show okay
this is really important the Trump
administration has documents showing
they know how many people might die if
states open too quickly it's a big
number and those documents have now
leaked of course the Trump
administration is not talking publicly
about any of this so when we ask the
question how many people will die of
coronavirus there is not one answer a
way of modeling there are confidence
intervals the death toll depends on
things that we can't control like how
contagious is coronavirus what is the
bottom line death rate the the fatality
rate of the virus
the death toll also depends on things we
can control like social distancing
whether we open States too early whether
we find a treatment or a vaccine now
publicly
the Trump administration has taken the
approach of claiming that the baseline
if he did nothing would have been 2.2
million deaths Trump often says I could
have done nothing and 2.2 million people
would have died but I've done stuff so
we're gonna be way below that now no
president could really get away with
doing nothing once you start mitigation
the possible death toll starts to
decline one model said could be one
hundred and fifty to two hundred and
fifty thousand another said could be one
to two hundred thousand and eventually
as more and more governors closed down
projections kept improving down to
roughly sixty to seventy thousand deaths
for wave one in which we are right now
the wave one thing is important because
more and more medical experts think
there will be a second wave of the virus
starting in the fall possibly a third
wave in 2021 okay let's put that aside
for now the important question now is
after going through weeks of mitigation
what would happen if we reopen States
too early we had a record single day
death toll this week we are have very
high numbers of deaths we are still
finding 25,000 or more new cases every
single day in the United States we're
hopefully in the peak the peak is a
plateau it can last a month or so if we
do everything right so when Texas and
Georgia and other states plan to reopen
tomorrow and Monday and other days next
week it's very risky now Trump was asked
a few days ago are you worried about a
resurgence in the virus if states open
too quickly
have you modeled what those numbers
would look like and Trump said if we did
nothing we would have lost two million
people now we won't the truth though is
we know that they do have models about
what happens if they open too early and
they're really really bad before we look
at the models here's Trump's answer when
he was asked about this a few days ago
[Music]
the possibility there is a widespread
resurgence this just doesn't work
so if we didn't do what we did we were
talking about up to 2.2 million deaths
so that's five times almost what we lost
in the Civil War okay if everything
happens properly and if we continue to
go the way we're going now we will be
significantly less than the lowest
number with mitigation so we'll be
significantly less and it's a lot of
people now Trump first of all didn't
answer saying if I did nothing we would
have 2.2 million deaths the question was
have you modeled what would happen if
you open too early the answer is a
simple yes and we have those models
Trump gave that ridiculous answer on
April 17th but in early April the
federal government put together models
of what happens if social distancing
stops too quickly and the numbers are
anywhere from a middle-of-the-road guess
of 300,000 deaths all the way up to 1.8
million deaths this is a model from the
Department of Health and Human Services
Trump's administration had the data in
early April but Trump gave a bogus
answer
we now have their models and they are
very concerning the Department of HHS
has four scenarios and then they have
like a best guess which is in the middle
the models range from 94 thousand deaths
up to 1.8 million deaths Trump likes to
say thanks to me
we'll have 60,000 deaths instead of 2.2
million it's absurd but thanks to
opening too early you could have 1.8
million deaths
instead of 60,000 the best scenario
expects 94 thousand deaths there are
some in-between models up all the way up
to one which they peg at 1.8 million
deaths and then you have a sort of
average of these a best guess right now
which says if you open too early about
300,000 people are going to die so there
are multiple things to think about here
first Trump was asked have you modeled
this and he didn't answer it's possible
he saw this model but he won't admit it
that's a problem of dishonesty it's
possible he didn't even see it
that's a problem of Trump often not
having the facts because he lacks the
attention span to actually
absorb that information number two if
Trump wants to take credit for 60 K
instead of two million he would have to
take responsibility for 300 K or a
million or 1.8 million instead of 60 K
if it's a result of states opening too
early thanks to his public posturing
about opening up the economy now over
the last 24 hours he has finally said
you know I think maybe Georgia is
opening up too early and it's possible
someone got to him and said you can't be
on the side of encouraging this because
it's going to be really bad but the most
important takeaway is the government has
the data they know the risks and they
have the numbers and yet Trump and Fox
News have mostly still been fomenting
these freedom and liberty protests
around the country from people just
demanding that governor's let it rip
people will die we now know that they
know it and the next thing I want to
talk about is the astroturfed protesters
that we have seen